what is critical race theory we all use
this term
and yet people don't seem to know what
it means
well you can read the academic
literature on it it's developed by this
woman kimberly crenshaw or a number of
other people
who've contributed to this particular
subset of critical theory but it's
probably easier just to watch a video on
what critical theory looks like
in action here is ashley shackleford a
quote
queer agender black fat femme writer
artist
and cultural producer she is giving a
lesson
through the analytical lens of critical
race theory to a group of deluded and
poor white people i think it's sort of a
mixed mixed crowd here
this is what crt looks and sounds like
in practice
white people are racist so i put this up
because i really want
any white person in the room to know up
front that this is what we're dealing
with
that it's not going to be this coddling
of white tears
and what that looks like we're not going
to discuss oh maybe some of us have
worked it out
no you're always going to be racist
actually so even when you're on your
path to trying to figure out how to be a
better human being
um because i believe that white people
are born into not being human
like that actually instead of people of
color and black folks being dehumanized
that actually everyone is dehumanized
off rip within white supremacy
that y'all are born into a life to not
be human and that's what y'all are
taught to do
to be demons so in this particular way
white people are all racist there you
have it
there's the lesson did you take notes i
hope you took notes
so that you can crumple them up and
throw them in the fire this sort of
stuff
is not just valueless this sort of woman
doesn't just have
nothing of value to say this sort of
stuff
is bad for your brain it's bad for your
mind it's anti-education
it's making you dumber and less
well-behaved and less sophisticated
it needs to be banned from the classroom
like you would ban
poison from your recipes it is so
so stupid there is no free marketplace
first of all
there is no free marketplace of ideas in
the classroom period
that's a hoax that's a farce another
insight of william f buckley jr
people set the curriculum the harvard
law professor adrian vermeel just
pointed this out the other day he said
for the love of god people
the high school classroom is not the
free marketplace of ideas
it's a place to convey certain
information and to convey education
a coercive act with curricula that are
set by school boards and by politicians
and by administrators
it is not the this free-flowing place of
debate that's not how it works in
practice it's not even how it works
in theory you need you need
to say no i know we only want to say yes
and be the nice inclusive guys
to something like critical race theory
to all white people are racist in their
demons
you have to say no hey i am so pleased
that you have enjoyed this content
you've watched it through to the end you
want more but you're not getting more
because you haven't rung the bell you
got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe you got to like it you got to
get the notifications then i would
suggest maybe head on over
to apple podcast google play stitcher
spotify myspace zanga
anywhere you got the michael knowles
show audio podcast and while you're at
it
you can pre-order my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now
only for a few more days thank you we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you